i'm gavin i'm the solo developer behind
two star games and i'm currently making
choo choo charles
[Music]
it's an open world horror game where you
navigate an island in an old train
[Music]
upgrade over time and then use it to
fight an evil spider train named charles
if you pump enough lead into his face
i'll probably encourage him to run off
and find something else
you have one goal above all else and
that's to summon charles to a 1v1 and
fight him to the death
to do that you'll need to explore the
open world looting abandoned areas and
completing missions for the locals to
gain powerful new weapons and scraps
that you can use to upgrade your trains
speed armor and damage
only believe the relative safety of your
train and venture out on foot
[Music]
this is where things get really
dangerous with charles constantly
roaming around looking for his next meal
and camps of shotgun wielding cultists
looking for someone to feed to him
[Music]
[Music]
after collecting three heavily guarded
gems from abandoned mines around the
island you'll place the gems on one of
the shrines angering charles and drawing
him to your location
[Music]
best be careful out there because it
might be unwise to wander too far from
your train
if you do encounter charles while you're
roaming around it doesn't matter what
you do now because you have truly
angered the beast and you'll either
escape with your life
or see it flash before your eyes
if it sounds like something for you be
sure to follow and wish list choo choo
charles on steam i'd greatly appreciate
it really does mean a lot